remember those human skills we talked
about listening giving and receiving
feedback you know there's that these are
these are the opportunities for those
skills to operate does it matter if this
team is a short-term team or a long-term
team it doesn't matter right a team is
not a group of people who work together
a team is a group of people who trust
each other
and just because you were assigned to
work with somebody doesn't mean you're a
team yet you have to do the hard work of
building a team and creating teaming
um and uh whether a leader is assigned
or whether a leader emerges
um and it doesn't matter the rank uh uh
a leader recognizes that they have a
responsibility to see those around them
rise it's not about them and their Glory
it's not about I did all the work you
know
um and what's fascinating is a team of
average performers is outperform a team
of high performers every day
um for all of the reasons we're talking
about
um which is are you in service to your
team are you in service to yourself
when I used to teach way back when
um
I did team projects and the university
advised me when because I made the teams
I didn't let them choose
I would put my top performers on one
team
I'd put my bottom performers on another
team and then I'd spread out the average
because my original Instinct was to take
my top performers and put one of them on
each team right and the university said
don't do that and so I followed the
University's guidance and I put all my
top performers on one team and literally
as I announced the teams in the class
the rest of the class were like come on
like I'd stack the deck
my top performers never ever ever got
the best grade for their group projects
never
my top performers spent more time in my
office going but I'm doing all the work
and that person's not doing the work and
is it going to affect my grade and what
happens about my grade my grade me me me
me me
the average performers
because they knew that they were middle
of the pack they worked together a hell
of a lot better
and they always every year outperform
the top team every single year because
they were devoted to their team rather
than themselves they're more concerned
about each other's grades in the group
grade rather than my grade
and so that's part of teaming it's
showing up for the team and service team
not worrying about the disparities of
who's doing more or less work it doesn't
matter
right
um uh if somebody's doing less work then
brush them aside like so what they're
gonna get your grade I mean welcome to
life you know
um uh yeah it's unfair
um yeah yeah congratulations yes it's
unfair you did all the work and they got
a good grade what do you care about them
worry about yourself right
um and and so this is this is what
teaming is the hard work of teaming is
actually the hard work of learning to
build deep meaningful relationships and
I guarantee you if you can learn the
skills to be a better listener a better
team player at in your group project you
will find weird things happening in your
friendships and your relationship with
your parents and your siblings and your
girlfriends and your boyfriends which is
you'll notice that those relationships
are getting better too because the
skills are human skills and the
transferable professionally or
personally